good morning and good afternoon ladies
and gentlemen and welcome to today's
live broadcast raising antibody
validation standard with knockout
technology my name is Jessica from Abbe
cam and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
ab cam as an innovator in reagents and
tools as cams purpose is to serve life
science researchers globally to achieve
their mission faster providing the
research and clinical communities with
tools and scientific support the company
offers highly validated biological
binders and assays to address important
targets and critical biological pathways
already a pioneer in data sharing and II
conference in life sciences AB cam
submission is to be the most influential
company in life sciences by helping
advance global understanding of biology
and causes of disease which in turn will
drive new treatments and improved health
for more information please visit
www.dent.umich.edu/license as we can
during the Q&A session you can also
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you have
any technical problems while viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
hand side of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button found in the lower left-hand
side this is an educational webinar and
thus offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the C e button located in the
bottom left-hand cool
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits I would now
like to introduce today's speaker
Alejandra Solich dr. siwash joined IBM
in 2013 as head reagents product
development and manufacturing globally
she is responsible for managing the
output and specifically the new product
development Cori agents and Rd she also
plays a key role in developing AB camp
innovation strategy
prior to joining ab cam she held various
positions at EMV milla por literally as
R&D director leading the antibody and
assay development teams she gained
expertise in immunology cell signaling
and cell biology through postdoctoral
fellowships at UCSF and the Trudeau and
Institute I will now turn it over to
Alejandra for her presentation Alejandra
it's all yours
Thank You Jessica hi everyone and thank
you for being here with us I am really
glad to be able to share with you one of
our most exciting initiatives in our
camp which is the incorporation of
knockout technology in our antibody
validation and this effort is quite
important for us and we believe also for
the scientific community since it
contributes to increasing industry
standards for antibody validation and
ultimately to increase reproducibility
of research and the aim of this
presentation today is to give you an
overview of some of the tools available
to address and the specificity and
reproducibility issues of research
reagents in particularly in particular
we will discuss outcomes initiatives to
tackle them and importantly we also will
discuss how can we all collectively
contribute to solve these issues and why
are we all concern about this and why
are we in a camp paying so much
attention to this as you probably are
all aware there is an issue with
reproducibility in biomedical research
in 2012 a study led by dr. Begley and
ambien was only able to reproduce six
out of 53 cancer studies and this
highlighted a big issue some of the had
a red flag that he found out where for
this is a producible research included
the selected presentation of positive
data the lack of blinded studies or
controls and particularly lack of pre
invalidation and lack of reagent
validation has been already highlighted
in multiple report recently in the
literature and publications and and and
this is no news for anyone something
that is making things worse is the fact
that there is peer reporting when when
in the literature when people report how
they did their experiments and what
reagents they have used these studies
don't have enough information containing
catalog number vendors and all the
information related to the reagents that
have been used in the research which
makes very difficult for other
researchers to follow up I try to
reproduce that research and all the
reproducibility and reagent validation
have always been on the agenda for
science we actually we may wonder why
these issues are rising more now and one
important factor is that we have wider
access to advanced technologies so there
are many new tools in life sciences such
as mass spectrometry high throughput
arrays we have now the ability to knock
out and knock down genes and I'll Delta
and we put cadastre protein expression
in cells for animals and and this is
becoming
in these techniques are becoming a lot
more accessible to everyone and
therefore have created opportunities to
better assess reagent specificity and
reliability and allow us to be more
precise than ever before so it's not
surprising that the widespread acts the
widespread access to these new
technologies and improved validation
methods has uncovered issues with most
common reagents in particular with
antibodies and these issues have been
reported as well by several papers and
opinion pieces in nature and science and
many other scientific journals and they
have been implicating antibodies as an
important factor contributing to the
wider problem of reproducibility in
research and this is highlighting a
problem that has to be tackled
collectively and in fact there are
several organizations and initiatives
such as the Global dialogues all
standards institute who are advocating
for better antibody standards and as
part of our commitment to improve
quality standards in Afghan with
recognize that it is important that the
agent suppliers do more to tackle these
issues and this means offering support
to different industry negatives
improving manufacturing processes and
adopting more robust validation
technologies as developed so specificity
and reproducibility need to be addressed
and and they need to be addressed not
just by interior producers but also by
and it should be done by a wider effort
in the scientific community
researchers have a responsibility and
also scientific journals editors have
also a role to play here and this is
something that we
to address today in this webinar and in
today's presentation we will discuss how
antibody types and the manufacturing can
affect consistency including the
benefits of using recombinant monoclonal
we will reduce some of the most advanced
methods using antibody validation and we
will also describe our new initiative of
antibody validation by knockout models
and finally we will discuss steps that
both researchers and suppliers can take
to promote reproducible research through
the use of quite high quality and
diverse reagents and transparent
reporting okay starting with what kind
antibiotic suppliers and companies that
produce reagents - - and the most
important step that antibody producers
can take to ensure consistency is to
adopt high standards in manufacturing
practices and and make sure that they
have robust validation technologies as
we highlighted already the performance
of an antibody can be closely linked to
how they are manufactured and antibodies
are available as you know in two forms
polyclonal monoclonal and they both
types of antibodies have their benefits
and limitations depending on their
intended application
polyclonal antibodies the process of
generating these antibodies they
generate a large variety of antibodies
to different epitopes on one particular
antigen which can be advantageous for
some applications but also this can be a
significant source of background and
cross activity and the complexity of
polyclonal is further complicated by
their finite nation nature and once the
batch has been
depleted do you need to initiate an
immunization and therefore the antibody
performance could vary significantly
between batch to batch so while a
polyclonal may be comparatively
inexpensive in the short-term
maintaining consistency can become quite
labor-intensive so now moving on sonic
monoclonal monoclonal antibodies
recognize a single epitope and they
display higher specificity as many
monoclonal cell manufacture from
hybridoma lines and if properly
maintained they should not have batch to
batch variability they however in rare
cases may have stability issues and lose
epitope recognition so once a monoclonal
has been identified they it can continue
to be produced by culturing through
hybridoma cell line and alternatively
the antibodies may be produced as
recombinant antibodies and to generate a
recombinant antibody the genes encoding
the antibody binding region the heavy
and light chain of the antibodies can be
cloned into a vector that will permit
the expression in a more robust hostile
line which could be a choice a line or a
heck to 9-3 the line for example from
here the resulting the communal antibody
can be isolated and purified just as if
they had been produced through a
hybridoma but once the antibody sequence
recommendin antibodies are then subject
are not subject to loss of activity and
which could be caused by sequence drift
or other issues that could be affecting
standard hybridomas when they are poorly
maintained and once an antibody has the
inclin'd the recombinant antibody
production is scalable and since it is
full in vitro system is you are able to
produce consistently antibodies that are
identical from batch to batch
furthermore the engineer nature of the
recommended antibodies makes it easier
to improve both antibody specificity and
sensitivity if it is required so along
with the benefits of recombinant
antibodies recombinant ravine monoclonal
or lab map antibodies offer additional
advantages since they are generated in
rabbit they can be developed to a
diversity of epitopes and this is due to
the ability of the rabbit immune system
to see multiple very small differences
due to a larger PCL repertoire and they
tend to be higher higher have higher
sensitivity than mouse monoclonal and
the reactivity across species can be
better because they can actually work
for example in rodent models and in
Ephram
we have about 90% of our rabbit
monoclonal are made recombinant Lee and
therefore they will also have all the
advantages that we have just described
for recombinant antibodies
so recombinant antibodies may require a
high degree of technical expertise and
can be comparatively expensive to
produce or in the past we're actually
comparable expensive to produce to a
standard hybridoma however technology in
this area is developing rapidly and the
cost and timelines of production are
actually coming down and the advent of
stage is play and other displaced
technologies have allowed monoclonal
antibody discovery processes to take
place with minimal or no animal
involvement and since no immunization
steps are required a comprehensive phage
antibody libraries and permit the
targeting of antigens which could
potentially be toxic or may have low
antigenicity which will be difficult to
generate two standard hybridoma
technologies and we are extremely
excited with the addition of the exam
extend ology to of them because it
provides a unique fast and efficient
platform to produce recombinant
monoclonal antibodies which complement
outcomes existing production
capabilities so we have now discussed a
lot to do with manufacturing practices
and the different types of antibodies
and the pros and cons and selecting a
polyclonal or standard monoclonal or a
recombinant monoclonal for you reach for
your own research will will have an
impact on your experimental results but
it is important to be aware that each of
those may have benefits and limitations
and and some of them may be suited for
certain applications however regardless
of the type of antibody or the type of
production all antibodies require
stringent validation
and this is what we will be discussing
now antibody validation has been
evolving since antibodies were first
used as reagents Western blood immuno
precipitations immunohistochemistry
immunofluorescence and many other
techniques have been available for over
30 years and all of them have advantages
and disadvantages and and depending on
the type of antibody that you want to
obtain or the research that you are
carrying out you will try to reduce an
antibody that has been Bala dated in a
particular application and more recently
more advanced techniques like knockout
knock down or peptide ray or mass
spectrometry have been more widely
available and are becoming increasingly
popular however there is no single
solution to antibody validation and some
methods are exceedingly powerful but
come with major resource considerations
that some labs may be may actually
struck to a struggle to meet and you
need to find the most efficient and
appropriate solution for urine for
Jerome projects for your own experiments
and researchers need to weigh up the
cost and time restraints and in some
cases even the level of technical
expertise or involvement of some of
these techniques so let's start with
mass spectrometry mass spectrometry is
typically used following IP and where
antibodies are linked to beads used to
pull a target of interest from a complex
solution and they recovered proteins are
then digested in and the protein
fragments are analyzed and this
technique is very amenable to high
throughput formats however it may come
with some issues like low sensitivity
we do actually sometimes could pull down
target proteins that have been complexed
with your target and the antibody needs
to remain up to be able to
immunoprecipitate the target and also it
requires access to a mass spectrometer
so moving on to protein arrays protein
arrays are quite high tech high
throughput and they can compare the
antibody The Binding of an antibody to a
target peptide and also compared to the
binding to off target peptides and this
is a very good technique when validating
antibodies to specific protein
modifications we particularly use this
technology to validate our antibodies to
different histone modifications and also
to phosphorylated proteins it allows
screening of large numbers or
overexpress proteins as well for example
when you are not using peptides and and
it is a very general it can provide a
lot of information about specificity the
only issue is that this an in vitro
assay and that it doesn't really have is
you don't have the cellular contest
contest in here okay now there are many
models of knockdown a knockout
technologies and in the case of the
knock knock down mode methods and this
in general use small interfering RNA and
this is use to reduce or deplete mRNA of
a protein of interest and therefore you
can compare the specificity of your
antibody to your target when this
protein is being down regulated in a
particular cell line
and this is a technology that has been
widely used and several companies are
actually using this technology and and
and it is it is quite good however
sometimes the facts could be transient
do sometimes and not able to eliminate
the protein of interest completely and
actually the experiments are quite
difficult to optimize often requiring
several SI RNA sequences so now moving
on to the knockout methods and the
knockout models allow scientists to
understand the function of a particular
gene in a whole animal or cellular
models that lack the protein of interest
in the context of antibody screening or
antibody characterization knockout
models provide an excellent standard for
antibody validation as they represent a
true negative control and as such they
are often viewed as the gold standard
for antibody validation and in recent
years the use of cusp crystal has 9
genome editing and has been able to at
to achieve this knockouts in a larger
scale and it's actually becoming quite
an important technique for widely do
swimming so many people and knockouts
align controls won't always be
appropriate though and and as essential
genes cannot be knocked out anyone that
is studying a gene that is vital to cell
survival for example simply will not
have the option to create to create a
directive controlled using knockout
technology and in the case of animal
knockout models obviously they will
require access to animal facilities and
expertise and in general this type of
technologies can be quite time-consuming
and expensive to generate
so unfortunately there isn't one size
fits all approach to antibody validation
suppliers need to make use of the most
appropriate available techniques when it
comes to validating their antibodies
whether it is mass spec or peptide raise
knockout knock downs either of them can
be quite powerful ideally use in
combination with all their technologies
what is very important is a transparency
of the validation methodologies is there
and so that researchers can be confident
of their products and and that they have
sufficient quality and and enough
validation for them to to be able to to
trust the particular antibody in Afghan
we have been using several knockout
models for quite a while already to
validate antibodies and we did these
through acquiring of some clones from
but collaborating with researchers who
have some type of knockout models or
purchasing when they were available or
even developing our own however the
scale that we could reach doing it this
way was extremely small and one of the
great advancements in science has been
the discovery of the editing by certain
molecules as we discussed CRISPR class 9
has quickly become greatly applied and
well Joseph's technology for precise and
efficient genome editing and this
technology has presented us with a great
opportunity to validate the specificity
of our antibodies at an unprecedented
scale and we are now utilizing human
knockout cell lines
from cellular models to develop growing
range of knockout validated antibodies
and in order to do these we have been
working with exclusive exclusive supply
agreement with horizon discovery and
horizon discovery uses crystal cast nine
technology and and not only that they on
top of the fact that this is already a
transformative enough technology another
great advantage of horizons discovery
platform these added uses a haploid cell
line which eliminates potential masking
of the knockout from a second allele
that might be seen in diploid cell
models so how are we doing this
validation how are we undergoing this
testing wanting to say that the knockout
validation is being done on top of other
applications that we have been using
already for the particular antibodies we
then have selected several antibodies to
a particular target we take several
endogenous several cell lines where the
protein of interest is endogenous be
expressed and we also test wall type and
knockout have one cell lines which is
the horizon discovery cell lines and we
test either by Western blot or by ICC
and some of the expected results that we
see are we have three different type of
results first of all the idea of
scenario is when the target with the
antibody specific for the target of
interest and in this package
our case as you can see as you can see
on the first Western blot we have an
antibody that recognizes the pkc alpha
protein in the wall type have one cell
line and in two cell lines that we have
used as positive cell lines but the band
of interest disappears in the knockout
cell line and this is great this is what
we want to see so what we will do with
this data is to upload it into a website
and and we will ask our seal of knock
out validated antibody the second case
is the case where the antibody of
interest already we knew that had some
closure activity and but we wanted to
identify if the band at the correct
molecular weight expected for that
particular protein in this case rip
actually will go away to I highlight if
this particular antibody recognized
ripped rip or not in the context of this
knockout and what we see here is that
the band of interest disappears in the
knockout and however the other band that
is an off target binding stays there and
the design Tavares can still be useful
particularly when they are not that many
antibodies to the target and we believe
that is better to have an antibody for
which knockout validation has been done
at least you know what you are getting
that having something else that may be
completely recognizing a totally
different protein the worst-case
scenario obviously is when you have a
protein that recognizes something else
completely different and that you
thought was the protein the protein of
interest because the protein of interest
has the same molecule
wait however what we find here is that
the band of interest doesn't go away in
the Knockouts hairline and and this is
great because now with this technology
we are able to detect that this antibody
was not specific and and we don't need
to keep it in the catalog so we'd remove
the product from the catalog we notified
the people that have purchased that
particular antibody and we also offer
ideally one or two other antibodies that
have been validated in knockout to the
same target so for the in the case of
the antibodies that cannot that don't
work in Western blot and there are many
antibodies that that fantastic
antibodies would not necessarily work in
Western blot we are doing these same
testing using immune cytokines tree in
this particular case an antibody against
Kye 67 was tested in the wall type heart
cell line and in the high six fifty
seven knockout top one and what we can
see here is that in the fourth panel at
bottom we see that the signal disappears
in the knockout say line so this is what
we are doing with all of our all the hab
one knockout cell lines but we are also
am doing a lot of validation still
through our collaborations and and this
contribute greatly to our internal
efforts and we would like to encourage
people to to continue doing this if you
have any knockouts available and want to
share your data we will love to hear
from you and in this particular case
this is data for about for an antibody
against PDL 1 and and our collaborators
on send us some beautiful data to show
that the antibody detects
one only on the parental cell line but
not in the PDL one knockout cell line so
we have discussed now all of the efforts
that we are doing on knockout validation
and so far we have around 400 primary
antibodies against several different
targets in many areas of research and we
are doing these because the research of
our customers is very important to us
and we want to take every measure to
ensure that our antibodies are
reproducible and robust as possible okay
so another thing that we believe that US
and other antibody providers should be
doing is being very transparent and and
offering the ability to customers to
provide feedback and we have we have
been doing this for many many years in
South can actually started we have this
AB review program that allows customer
to freely give positive and negative
feedback and to share their protocols so
we believe this is a really good thing
for cause for our you as a researcher
because it can help you choose the best
antibody you don't necessarily just need
to trust the data that the companies
provided but providing but you can
actually also see data that your peers
and colleagues are providing and the
last thing is to provide enough data and
information to help reproducible
research obviously companies need to
provide detailed protocols for the
application tested and highlight
applications where the particular
antibody works and ideally where doesn't
work and as long as as well as
in any other application that can be
relevant to that particular product so
we have talked a lot about what
companies can do and what suppliers
should be doing and but while defining
the initial quality of the antibodies at
task that falls to the suppliers
researchers at the bench have also a
vital part to play in promoting
reproducibility it is important to
understand that even a highly validated
antibody can yield unreliable results if
the experimental protocols and controls
are not in place
so obviously you all know that and there
are other things that view as a
researcher could be doing in order to
facilitate the produce ability of
research and one of them is to to check
that the applications and protocols that
you want to test the particular product
is what they the researcher sorry the
supplier has recommended and published
with detail antibody information or
reagent information using vendor catalog
numbers and all of the information that
will be useful for somebody else to be
able to reproduce your research and also
share your validation data and give
feedback is not only sites like us who
have they give you the ability to to
share your data but there are multiple
sites out there antibody pedia and other
sites that actually let you share data
which is very important so the last
another component of the community who
has to be engaged in this concerns about
reproducibility is the publishing
companies and journal editors need to be
supporting researchers by asking for
detailed information
such as a catalog number vendor and all
of the information required forth from a
particularly agent so that again the
research can be reproduced as closely as
possible and and ideally the company
should be providing information about
whether a particular reagent has been
also cited in the literature so moving
forward improving the reproducibility of
research across life sciences need to be
a partnership between all parties
involved and the suppliers the
researchers and publishers all need to
do their part and as we discussed
suppliers need to go to even greater
lengths to ensure that their antibodies
are sufficiently validated that there is
enough testing data and and and this is
the first step and the most vitals as it
allows researchers to the previous their
own research and when they are confident
that the antibody has been properly
validated but also as we have discussed
there is responsibility of people I do
in the lab to take care that that the
experiments are robust and I do publish
with enough data and for the scientific
journals to enforce completely agent
information as well and
so we believe that this partnership is
not only possible but is necessary and
and we believe that this is actually
already happening there are as we say
many consortiums and a lot of different
forums where people are getting together
to discuss how quick can improve this
and in summary today I want to we have
discussed what antibody producers need
to adopt the antibody producers need to
adopt high standards to manufacture and
validate their antibodies with a
combination of characterization methods
and I have highlighted our commitment to
continued support the support of
scientific researchers by validating
hundreds of antibodies per years using
knockout technologies and also by
introducing more recombinant antibodies
and also by evolving our validation
strategies as new tools become available
this improvement needs to be a
partnership between the antibody
producers their researchers and the
journal publishers and we hope this
presentation encourage you and all of
you involved in life sciences to take
what steps they can to contribute
towards the generation of consistent and
high-quality research and thank you for
your attention and I would really like
to hear any feedback or anything else
that you think we should be doing as a
community to help with reproducibility
thank you thank you Alejandra for that
informative presentation ladies and
gentlemen before we get started on the
question-and-answer session I'd like to
remind you how to submit questions you
can submit questions by typing them into
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left hand side
the presentation window will try to
answer as many questions as possible
will you be knockout testing all of your
antibodies well ideally we would like to
to test all of our antibodies however we
have lots of antibodies we will try to
to test as many as we can and obviously
as discussed already some of these some
proteins had not actually expressed in
the hub in the cell line and also some
proteins are necessary for the survival
of the cells so it won't be possible to
to test them and with this methodology
but we will try to use a different
methodology for those cases thank you
for that as a follow-up we have a
similar question will you be knockout
testing all of your antibodies to a
specific target well it is the same
thing depending on the target we will be
testing the antibodies if they are AB if
we have the knockout cell line available
or or if there is a a knockout Mouse
available so it will really depend on
the target okay and on a similar note
again how are you choosing the target to
test and knock out cell lines sorry
could you repeat that question yep how
are you choosing the targets to test in
these knockout cell lines so we are
selecting this target based on one
availability of the the knockout cell
line and to base
how widely used it is for researchers
have done it will be this target to be
to be validated in the research
community okay thank you for that so
kind of moving on a little bit how can a
scientist avoid using the wrong reagent
with knockout technology and so dr.
technology is only one part of the
quality and the validation and outcome
we validate antibodies using many
complementary techniques as we discussed
like Western blot ICC I'd see and and
knock out and knockdown can be also also
considered okay thank you
regarding the experiments used for the
knockout and what is published on the
data sheets what is the number of repeat
experiments Western blot or immuno Saito
chemistry that you do for validating the
antibodies prior to including this
information on the datasheet and I'm
sorry
I really couldn't hear very much of that
that okay I'm sorry about that the
question really is referring to the
number of repeats of experiments that
are performed prior to including that
data on the website or on the data sheet
oh oh we will do many experiments in
probably in excess of five different
experiments to include data in the data
sheet okay wonderful
so when you use these knock out cell
lines for antibody validation do we
generally have any negative results and
can you share some of these negative
results how are these negative results
interpreted oh yes
absolutely and I did show one of those
negative results and I can go back and
ensure it to do in here yes second we
have one of the examples that that we
showed was a negative result so this is
in the data piece in number three that's
of that is actually an antibody that was
negative in or basically actually show a
band in the knockout where we respect
not to have the band of interest and so
in those cases we remove that particular
antibody from the website okay that's
good to know
regarding the rabbit monoclonal
antibodies we see that some are not
validated for flow cytometry is there
any reason for this oh yeah definitely I
think well the nature of the antibodies
means that not all of the antibodies are
going to to work for one particular
application or another one
we often have antibodies that work both
in icc and flow and and we use ICC for
knockout validation but not necessarily
not all antibodies necessarily will work
in flow cytometry it there it really it
really is quite variable
okay so regarding different applications
we perform batch testing of antibodies
on knockout sample we do we we will
provide batch testing for only
polyclonal antibodies in knockout
samples a monoclonal antibody due to the
nature of the lack of batch to batch
variability we believe that when we have
validated the actual clone we want it to
be validating that clone again every
time we make a new batch but but we will
be validating that particular monoclonal
in in the other applications that we
that we always do okay thank you for
that
I'm similarly are you only validating
products made at IBM are you also
validating outsourced product are
validating not only outcome products we
are validating the antibody that we
consider that are necessary reduce for
that will be useful for for the customer
or we are actually validating a lot of
outcome internal antibodies because we
have the actual clones and we have we
are trying to incorporate these on the
production and they understand that
validation of the clones but we are
actually going back to validate some non
Afghan products as well
okay so it sounds like validating for
both ab cam as well as outsourced
products which is wonderful and so when
performing these validations with
knockdowns generally how many cell lines
are used and this question is regards to
the consideration that the pattern can
be different from cell line to cell line
depending on your target yes so we are
using one cell line knockouts a line
however we are also using different
other cell lines which express the
protein endogenously and and so we the
knockout is just extra an extra piece of
information when we have had some
inconclusive information we have tried
to get access to a different knockout
cell cell type or or a different
knockout model as well okay so it sounds
like there's a lot of research going
into the different reagents that are
being used so on that note how do you
check that the protein is really knocked
out in the cell lines that are being
used this is something that that our
colleagues add discovery the horizon
discoveries have being have been doing
they have their quality control checks
and they do all of this testing
themselves and we could actually you
could check their website to get that
information one thing we do though is to
test multiple antibodies to the same
target so in if in a particular case we
had doubts that the cell line is not
expressing the protein of interest we
will be we will be checking with
multiple different antibodies okay
and this actually is a good segue into a
follow-up question that just came in
some antibodies detect a protein bands
of different size than are expected do
you think that these antibodies are
specific to the target protein or is
there potentially another explanation
for this well that depends for many
things for example glycosylation and all
their modest translational modifications
may alter the size of the protein and
and actually it could also be depending
on on this cell type and and any type of
modifications that could happen
endogenously okay so it sounds like it's
a case-by-case situation to be looked at
yes okay so regarding the stage display
there is actually a two-part question so
what is the size and diversity of the
stage display library and what is
displayed in the phage display library
display library is an excess of 10 to
the ninth launched and and the
single-chain AP are displayed but then
these are converted to a GG's for
product market
okay and we have one final follow-up
question so during the talk you
mentioned that use a leukemic cell line
for this knockout validation do you feel
that this gives suitable coverage of
targets for example what about in the
neuroscience area well the this is a
leukemic cell line but it doesn't mean
that it wouldn't express proteins so if
the particular proteins regardless of
being neuroscience or or not and this
the cell line could actually Express the
same proteins so if the protein and is
expressed in this hub one cell lines
they it will be it will be possible to
use it so these cell lines are
transformed like many of the transformed
cell lines express many other targets
wonderful Thank You Alejandra and thank
you ladies and gentlemen at this time
I'd like to start wrapping up today's
webinar so first I'd like to thank you
ladies and gentlemen for your
participation today and of course Thank
You Alejandra for presenting if we were
unable to answer your question we look
forward to reaching out to you following
the webinar via email at this time I'd
also like to thank our sponsor AB kam
for making today's educational webcast
possible so ladies and gentlemen today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through December you will
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to fold this
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event so with
that we'd like to wish you good luck
with your research and we hope that you
have a wonderful rest of your day